well thank you Bob for that marvelous
introduction or Dean Joss as he's now
come to be known he told he told you one
of my flaws I've searched for years and
years to find the dark side of Bob I
haven't found it yet but I want you to
know I will pay richly if you can give
me a story a little later in thy speech
I want to talk about some of my personal
lessons of life there might be a passing
interest to you but let me begin my
remarks with one of those lessons one
that I think you should never forget and
that is only ever work for quality
people and never ever compromise on that
I'm fortunate enough to have been able
to execute on that strategy but as most
things in life you need a bit of luck to
do so and I was exceptionally lucky to
have the privilege and the pleasure to
work under your Dean Bob Joss for six
exhilarating years
Westpac is today the ninth largest bank
in the world by market capitalization
but it was well and truly on its knees
in the early 1990s when Westpac was
fortunate enough to lure Bob away from
another one of the world's great banks
Wells Fargo and I think it's fairly safe
to suggest that I was Bob's number two
for most of those six years and we had a
lot in common we both had PhDs in
economics and finance from some of the
world's great universities we both took
our first jobs in our respective federal
Treasuries we both loved solving complex
problems we're both absolute suckers for
facts and logic we both read a lot
we both had very strong work ethics we
were both great supporters of
meritocracy and we were fierce opponents
of corporate politics and we're both
tennis tragic
but there the similarities end
for as you'll be aware Bob is as we term
it in Australia simply a great bloke
there is no higher compliment an
australian can play anyone than to turn
them a great bloke and everyone has ever
worked with
above or below Bob will readily attest
to that by contrast I was a complete
pain in the arse to manage I was overly
ambitious
I was opinionated I was tragically low
on empathy I was openly and overly harsh
on what I thought weak ideas or
insufficiently dedicated effort and I
was often wrong but I was never in doubt
so most people wouldn't have tolerated
me but Bob persevered - subtly but
certainly mentor managed and coached me
occasionally with some suitably tough
love to a point with his support I was
able to succeed him as CEO of Westpac
you don't get much luckier than to have
a mentor and a coach and a boss and a
friend like Bob Joss
so Bob my debt to you is incalculable
and I can think of no better place than
right here to publicly and humbly thank
you for your counsel and your guidance
and your wisdom and your friendship in
those years and beyond
I'll never forget it and I'll never take
it for granted to all of you may you
just have a fraction of the luck that
I've had in that crucial respect
in the remainder of my remarks today I
intend to cover three topics first the
global financial crisis and policy
responses secondly corporate social
responsibility in corporate ethics and
thirdly as alluded to already some of my
lessons of life a full lecture couldn't
do justice to any one of them so I
apologized advanced to seeking to cram
three such topics into a single session
inevitably the coverage will be
hopelessly thin and I apologize in
advance for that first the GFC the
causes the crisis were manifold but
included complacency towards risk
build-up during an exceptionally long
boom stretching over 16 years reflected
in lacks lending standards and
watered-down risk management
unrealistically low interest rates and a
wall of money seeking enhanced returns
contributing to excessive leverage
innovation complexity opacity of risk in
a wide variety of structured credit and
other instruments investors were removed
from the origination process and placed
a lot of faith in ratings agencies these
innovations outpaced the capacity of
financial institutions and regulators to
manage risk and compensation systems
that in many places were not closely
linked to long-term profitability and
value creation the conversion of
mortgage securities from huge illiquid
assets owned by local banks into liquid
financial instruments that could be sold
across the world combined sophisticated
US financial services dangerously with
relatively unsophisticated financial
services elsewhere the result of all of
the foregoing is a dysfunctional
financial system and clogged credit
markets in most parts of the world
probably the epicenter of the GFC was
the weekend prior to the collapse of
LeMans and the bailout of AIG JC flowers
the private equity firm owe him now work
with had a rather interesting weekend
that weekend on the Saturday morning we
were trying to buy a
with aliens iig said they were fine and
didn't need air pretty on Monday they
went to the Fed for an 85 billion dollar
bailout from the Saturday afternoon
we're in the ghost shooting to buy with
another party Lehman Brothers their
chairman told us to go packing Lehman
was of course bankrupt by the following
Monday we then spend Sunday as adviser
to the Bank of America on their Merrill
Lynch purchase which had to be
consummated before the opening of Asian
markets on Monday morning it was quite a
weekend one of the implications of the
GFC for the global economic outlook
plainly we nearly lost the global
banking system in September and October
of our wait that was a massive and very
public shock collapse or near collapse
of what was supposed to be some of our
safest institutions the leveraging is
now sweeping the world or more precisely
private sector deleveraging in response
the public sector is leveraging up
massively but a vicious circle is
underway credit rationing is hurting the
real economy this is causing more bad
debts in turn further impairing banks
willingness to lend hence world growth
is now projected to fall in 2009 to its
lowest rate since World War two while
recovery is forecast to begin in 2010 it
is impossible impossible to forecast
ahead by more than 12 months with any
degree of certainty this deep global
response is despite very wide-ranging
policy actions by governments in the
past six to nine months the private
sector de leveraging process currently
underway is necessary but needs to be
less disorderly it remains to be seen
whether the liquidity provision
provisioning the capital injections and
the measures to address and dispose of
problem assets are enough to ensure
sufficient balance sheet cleansing and
the restoration of confidence in the
long-term solvency of our major
financial institutions
history indicates that credit growth
remains sluggish until banks balance
sheets are cleansed so in summary
regarding the global outlook we will not
have another Great Depression we have
learned the policy lessons from that
mistake but the balance of probabilities
is that the global economy is almost
certainly set for the worst recession in
the post-world War two period let me
talk about the regulatory response
governments in most of the world at
present have an involvement in their
financial systems that is very extensive
moreover governments around the world
are claiming that the shortcomings in
the systems of financial regulation were
a if not these a significant contributor
to the GFC and the radical regulatory
reform is required
let me deal first with the interventions
themselves I have no quarrel with the
interventions today especially those in
late 2008 we nearly had a meltdown of
the global banking system in those
circumstances action was extraordinarily
urgent and needed to err on the side of
doing too much rather than too little
these measures avoided the very real
possibility of systemic collapse and
outcome too horrible to contemplate but
we are now past that cataclysmic point
these measures now need to be kept under
constant review and this is important
for two reasons first to remove the
distortions and the unintended
consequences of measures that had to be
devised and implemented urgently in a
crisis atmosphere and secondly to reduce
the imposition of significant
non-commercial objectives on to the
banking system by our political system
we're already seeing just how extensive
these non-commercial objectives are in
countries where governments have become
very heavily involved in their domestic
banking systems notably in the UK but
also to an extent here in the US
including executive compensation caps
required exclusive or near exclusive
focus on activity in the domestic market
and home mortgage foreclosure
forbearance
moreover we should not believe that we
have seen the end of this involvement
especially given the real possibility of
full or partial nationalization of
banking systems in several countries
it's understandable that there's some
public sympathy for such measures indeed
that's precisely what the politicians
are responding to there's literally
billions of taxpayer dollars have been
thrown at this carnage moreover there's
a lot of superficial appeal in the
argument that public sector ownership
and management could scarcely do any
worse than the private sector
counterparts they're replacing but
ongoing pursuit and entrenchment of
these non-commercial objectives in this
manner will take us a long way back to
the extreme bank regulation of the 1980s
and earlier I repeat the argument in
favor of reregulate is beguiling lis
simple banking was progressively and
significantly deregulated over the past
twenty to twenty-five years
the banking industry so the argument
goes has used those additional freedoms
recklessly more over the tab for that
mismanagement is being warned by the
general taxpayer pence so the argument
runs deregulation has been a failure and
bank regulation needs to be drastically
strengthened and reimpose the basic case
for regulation is that finance ears make
mistakes and frequently everyone else
mainly taxpayers has to pay for them
moreover finance feeds on trust and
mistrust and amplifies whatever is
ascendant and this is what makes
financial markets dangerous some
regulatory reform is undoubtedly
required first if something needs
rescuing it's a sign that it's needs
regulating there for hedge funds such as
long term credit management or an
investment banks such as Lehman's or an
insurance companies such as IG looks
large enough to threaten the system
there's a prima facie case for it to be
supervised regulators need to be charged
with protecting the financial stability
of the financial sector as a whole and
by that test after the past year the net
of Prudential Regulation needs widening
this raises the broader question of
regulations failure to evolve with the
shadow banking system private equity
hedge funds money market funds non
welcome you haven't missed much non
banks like GE Capital and new securities
such as CDOs and credit default swaps on
the eve of the crash more money was
flowing through this than the
conventional banking system but remember
that one of the reasons that these
organizations grew up was to avoid the
cost of regulation and wherever we draw
the new circle it is certain the new
entities will be designed to sit just
outside it secondly we do need measures
that will help reduce the notorious
procyclical bias of financial markets in
general and specifically of banks
restoring dynamic provisioning for risk
for credit risk is of urgent and helpful
first step thirdly monetary policy needs
to be guided by more than a single
figure for inflation there needs to look
more broadly at the build-up of
unsustainable imbalances beyond these
measures however the case for further
regulation remains to be proven in that
regard
it needs Speier emember there's no such
thing as a perfect market other than an
undergraduate textbooks all markets have
varying degrees of imperfection because
from time to time markets perform in a
particularly suboptimal fashion that is
not a sufficient condition to prove that
public ownership or extensive public
regulation is the right solution we need
to remember that public ownership
intervention and regulation are also
imperfect indeed highly imperfect
devices we need to remember the lessons
of heavy regulation comes at a heavy
cost especially in terms of lack of
innovation it results in an undoubtedly
safe but extremely stodgy banking system
uncompetitive and dynamic an innovative
and the intended affair
of deregulation of regulation I beg your
pardon are usually avoided by the more
nimble often with counterproductive
effects secondly regulation can be at
very best a third line of defense behind
management and behind boards regulators
have genuinely been painfully slow to
see the difficulties banking systems
were getting themselves into even slower
than the respective boards and
management corporate governance reform
is in my judgment a more pressing
priority the board structures in many of
these countries have been found severely
wanting I understand in the u.s. it's
still not uncommon for the CEO and the
Chairman to be the same person although
Bob tells me on the way over that's just
changed at Bank of America this morning
it's also not unknown for board members
in many countries to be cheerleaders of
the CEO Bob and I had no such luck at
Westpac in other cases boards are
chaired by people with no knowledge of
financial services surrounded by other
great and good friends of the Chairman
plainly we need to have people on these
boards who understand the financial
industry and are available frequently
this is especially true of the Risk
Committee which needs to free meet
frequently be semi-professional and be
capable of delivering opinions our
leiden to the interests of shareholders
plainly we will need to pay more for
this expertise and I'm not sure
everybody is ready to do so third and
this is a very hard thing to say when
you're running when your CEO running a
major bank being run by a regulator but
the fact is that regulatory agencies
everywhere have lost out and lost out
badly in the war for talent agencies are
staffed by people to generalize a worse
paid worse qualified and generally less
experienced than those they are seeking
to regulate and the gap is getting wider
one consequence is the talented people
in the private financial sector combined
with the fungibility of money and the
globalization of financial markets
combined to produce a formidable
pasady to circumvent much
well-intentioned regulation so let me
try and draw together my main
conclusions regarding the GFC and the
global economic outlook first we need to
have some humility in attempting to
forecast how the GFC will play out over
the period ahead because the stark fact
is no one knows however I do expect the
global recession to be the worst in the
post-war period but nothing approaching
a depression the speed with which
confidence and sentiment term is
paramount secondly I believe there is a
very significant threat around excessive
government intervention in financial
systems but I believe that risk to be
manageable secondly let me talk a little
about corporate social responsibility
and corporate ethics it was an issue
that we embraced fully and
enthusiastically at Westpac Westpac was
adjudged the leading bank in the world
for sustainability as judged by the Dow
Jones Sustainability Index for six of
the seven years from 2000 to 2007 the
Ethisphere Institute has just released
its 2009 list of 100 companies it
considers to be the most ethical groups
around the globe Westpac was the only
Australian company selected other
companies included honeywell Nike
Unilever General Mills and BMW Westpac
was on the 2008 list as well we pursued
this course of corporate social
responsibility and ethical behavior
vigorously for two disarmingly simple
reasons first was the right thing to do
secondly it was good for business we
didn't set out to win awards but what we
did was to lift the corporate veil and
seeing the underlying dimensions of
today's modern corporation
the economic engine that they constitute
and the social system of shareholders
employees and customers because when we
talk about meeting the needs of the
corporation we are really talking about
meeting the needs both of the economic
machine and of the social system that is
inseparable from it that is why managing
broad in the interests of our people and
our customers and contributing to
community building is so vitally
important in our case this was at the
very core of our service profit chain
business model which linked engaged
employees to satisfied customers to
value adding outcomes for shareholders
this is where we meet the logic of
managing ethically being a social system
that is part of larger society creates
an imperative to operate our businesses
in line with societal expectations to
operate our businesses in a responsible
ethical and trustworthy manner and being
so pervasive as Westpac was Australia's
first company founded in 1817 6.5
million customers twenty-seven thousand
employees hundreds of thousands of
shareholders meeting our own needs as a
business simply merged in the meeting
the needs of the community just as
critically our employees didn't leave
their values of the at the door when
they came to work on the contrary they
wanted to work with a company with a
decent set of values values that align
with their own it is a total fallacy to
think that you can today micromanage
individuals and determine the way that
they think especially our younger
generation it is strong corporate values
that are the glue that knits together
the company's social system and the
economics machine
this plan of ours were strategic it was
strategic in terms of managing our
regulatory and reputational risk
managing our social contract if you like
creating value adding opportunities by
understanding the emerging
socio-political environment and trends
better than others and driving that
through meeting the broader needs of our
people and our customers winning the
trust of our people was fundamental to
our success trust that you care about
them that you'll listen to them that
it's safe to speak up that you care
about what they think and value and
believe engendering a direct high trust
relationship with our people was I think
perhaps the company's most significant
and valuable achievement why is that
valuable it's valuable because such
employees are more efficient and they're
more productive from them you draw more
discretionary effort employees who enjoy
coming to work work more effectively
than employees you don't if they like
their work they're rewarded on merit
regardless of gender race or ethnicity
if the company's values align with their
own if they're proud of the company that
they work for they'll work harder they
will essentially manage themselves and
they stay longer with the company and
for the company these are huge
advantages so we said about building a
trustworthy responsible and ethical
organization values that simultaneously
met the needs of our organization and
the people that we wished to attract and
retain and that objective was at the
heart of our corporate responsibility
and sustainability program there is of
course another great benefit in all of
this because in our business employees
are literally inseparable from customers
because to our customers our employees
were the bank
because customers don't trust companies
they trust people the underpinnings of a
successful brand and our business is
most often a matter of the human
connection it's only humans who have
passion it's only humans who have
integrity and our customers judge the
credibility of our brand in large part
by the values of our people there is a
very direct correlation between loyal
employees and loyal customers and it's
in that correlation that shareholder
values substantially lies Bob said to me
during a visit of history Australia that
what most impressed him about Westpac in
2007 was the respect in which was held
and I believe that was in part about
being a company in tune with the needs
and the spirit of the present age I can
see some eye glazing in the audience
which is naturally at this stage of the
speech and saying did any of this adds
for shareholder value well we can't
prove that but when Bob and I first
joined Westpac there was a seriously
lagging number four of the big four
banks in Australia it lay well outside
of the world's top 50 banks by market
capitalization and its profitability was
poor by 2008 Westpac was the number one
bank in Australia by market
capitalization and the number two
company overall in Australia it was as I
mentioned the ninth largest bank in the
world by market capitalization and in
the most reputable annual survey of
global banking from Oliver Wyman
it was judged in 2008 the most
profitable large cap bank in the world
as measured by return on equity ethics
and corporate responsibility is good for
business as well as being the right
thing to do let me now turn to my third
and final section of my address today
and I'd like to show you a few clips of
my acting career it's okay just joking I
have reached that stage in my career
where ones perhaps entitled to look back
and reflect on some lessons of life and
my main message to you is that you live
your life the way you want to live it
and not for anyone else to make your own
choices not live somebody else's hopes
and dreams enjoy the terrific daring
adventure that now stretches before you
with all the hope and the optimism and
the energy and the enthusiasm that
you're obviously feeling today listening
to this lecture but most of all make it
your own
trust me that's actually not as easy as
it sounds in fact it's not easy at all
it certainly wasn't for me at least took
me the best part of a quarter century to
understand this and to make my life my
own I hope that an explaining briefly
how and why in my case will help you
achieve this goal much more quickly than
I managed my journey involved five
pivotal experiences out of which flowed
five priceless lessons which would have
changed my life irrevocably
my first lesson was with adversity comes
priceless opportunities when I was 10
years old
adversity ended our home in one fell
swoop
my mother left home my father went
bankrupt the bank sold their house and I
had to leave the school I attended that
experience taught me some difficult of
extraordinarily valuable truths that
everything changes men's but things
don't always go according to plan
life isn't always fair pain is a part of
life and people and it always there to
support you when you need them but
learning these truths early on helped me
cope with life more effectively I was
better equipped to handle
disappointments because I felt I'd
already been through a few serious ones
second thing the crisis did for me was
to tip me out of a third-rate
private school into a first-rate
selective government High School
Melbourne high school and I was there I
met one of the most important mentors in
my life Neville John and economics
master and loaded principal of the
school who taught me a love of economics
in commerce to stay with me all my life
and when I had to leave for financial
reasons secondary school prematurely at
the age of 16 it was again Neville who
had been finished my last school the
last years of secondary school by
correspondence while I was working full
time perhaps most importantly this
childhood trauma forged in me a steely
determination and drive that would stay
with me all my life I was absolutely
determined to work incredibly hard to
overcome that terrible feeling of not
being able to pay the rent or having to
cross the street to avoid the butcher
because we couldn't afford to pay the
weekly meat bill
why do I relate all this it's to say
that you don't despair when things go
wrong because out of adversity does come
priceless opportunities opportunities to
make your own choices choices that
determine not only what you're going to
do with your life but how are you going
to do it my second lesson was the talent
is necessary but not always sufficient
as I mentioned I had to leave secondary
school prematurely and for the next
three years I attempted to become an
actor it was my first career and I
failed failed very spectacularly and
that was hard because I really loved the
idea of acting and obviously launched
Olivia newton-john's career one thing
that I learned was the talent is
necessary but it's not always sufficient
I saw so many much more highly talented
actors than me who were unemployed for
very long periods of time and what they
needed was some luck and so much of life
is about being in the right place at the
right time and why is this important
because you have to realize that
sometimes things happen that are simply
outside your control you can't always
make things happen so you learn to
change what you can and accept what you
can't change and you don't beat yourself
up to say that you're not good enough
you make a choice to accept that this
time it didn't work out but there's a
whole other ocean of opportunities out
there to pursue so the important thing
is to stay optimistic and keep searching
often we're told to go after what we
love but in some ways that's bad advice
because in my judgement you have to find
not only what you love but also what
you're good at
I loved acting by the age of 19 I knew I
wasn't any good at it so Teddy I finally
made it to university I was older than
most other students but I knew firsthand
that life without secondary schooling
and tertiary education was going to be
very tough indeed so I was incredibly
motivated to really make the most of
University and I was probably equipped
with life skills learned through three
years in the workforce than those who
just drifted into it
academic life led me to my third pivotal
lesson and that is don't let fear of
failure hold you back but rather use it
to drive yourself do your best and back
yourself and you will almost certainly
surprise yourself
in a very positive manner let me
illustrate I won a scholarship to the
London School of Economics to begin the
master economics program and from the
start I was coming from behind because I
arrived a full month late and missed out
on the intensive maths and stats courses
essential for the rest of the master's
program why did I arrive late I'd been
playing professional football in
Canberra and we made the grand final but
winning that came came came at a very
big price I'd lost the first month of
study and I really thought I was going
to fail my masters because you need to
understand that fear of failure had long
been a part of my life but once again I
used that fear to fuel a huge burst of
hard work to get on top of my studies
and at the end of my master's exams I
went straight to work for the
International Monetary Fund on Nodine
Street in Washington DC and I very
nervously took a call from my professor
at the London School of Economics to
tell me of my Master's result and I
remember it like it was yesterday
feeling so afraid that I'd failed my
masters and my professor in his
inimitable very stuffy British
understated way told me you have done
tolerably well
thanks professor president anymore he
said you've passed in fact so that long
silence he said in fact you managed a
high distinction in your special subject
now the silence in fact you also managed
a high distinction in all the other
subjects oh and you also won the medal
for top student oh and it was also by a
margin managed by only one other person
in the entire history of the course said
almost as an afterthought even now I
can't truly Express what that meant to
me I proved myself to myself on the
world stage it was a turning point for
me in terms of self confidence it taught
me that I was capable of doing some
serious things with my life indeed that
I had to do something with this
world-class education and this newfound
confidence
there's a fourth lesson in my life that
I'd like to share with you today and
that is that while you can't have
everything you want in life you can have
any one thing that you want and that
means that sometimes you need to make
some tough choices so my message to you
today is that before you lies a daring
adventure and you'll have a lifetime of
interesting opportunities and many
choices perhaps more than any other
generation have the confidence to make
those choices your own and to live the
life you weigh the way you want to live
it for me it meant choosing between a
professional football career and a
scholarship at the London School of
Economics as a choice I never regretted
because even though I love football
I wonder the world-class postgraduate
education even more my fifth and final
lesson is that life is precious and very
very short so don't postpone looking for
happiness I've talked a lot about
pivotal moments and the importance
making the choices they're right for you
but the last point I touch on is the
most important of all when you search
for success don't forget to look for
happiness and don't take anything for
granted because life is precious
and every day counts this was brought
home to me not too long ago when my two
best friends died within a short period
of each other they were both the
Godfather successively of my daughter
and we're both brilliant men in the
prime of their lives and very
distinguished careers
soon after my wife Rose was diagnosed
with breast cancer it was a terrible
time for our family
and quite honestly nothing else matters
at the time that her health
fortunately they caught it early and she
recovered and enjoys good health today
but it absolutely brought home to me the
preciousness of life the fact that it
can be very short and you shouldn't
postpone enjoyment of life or your
happiness and we need to keep reminding
ourselves of that every single day
so step confidently forward to live life
on your own terms to know your inner
selves and use your strengths and your
values as your moral compass to chart
your own course because life is a
wonderful daring adventure to be enjoyed
with great happiness and whatever you do
make it your own thank you